[Music]  you've been in so many different roles  and uh you know andy and i were talking  about this today we've seen every movie  that you've done and one of the things  that uh we noticed today which is  thinking about it is that you have a  particular  acting technique you point a lot  you point a lot  in films and we actually  put together  a little montage  comparison forward  pointing behold  you find this man  you find this man  this is an obsession dad  i never understood it look jabba next  time you want to talk to me come see me  [Music]  if i go down you're going with me  you broke the law get out i'll look you  nor to you i did not sign up for this  marion ravenwood is your mother it may  not be a sufficient reply it's over  enough  enough  [Applause]  [Applause]